how are men not held accountable in this
situation exactly the point that he made
out that i'm not going to give her money
to go out to work in on the weekend if
you have a child with the woman that is
going to be the one that's going out to
work in take accountability that you put
your will in the wrong place okay okay
so he does he is he is held account
accountable because now he does have a
consequence
so well what is the woman's consequence
she has to be a mother and bring up the
child no but she gets free money wait
hold a minute she's like that's a freak
like a consequence okay bringing up a
kid for a woman because i thought i
thought i thought women are maternal so
the idea of having a kid is something
that it should be stressful
and also you chose to have that child
nobody just rang your doorbell and said
there you go either
way the whole point is that the women
don't have a consequence in this
situation because they get child support
they get alimony money isn't the same as
the thing is you're bringing up the
child and andy and they get custody
you're right so and on top of that the
dude doesn't even get to see his kid as
much well he should be safe but it's not
that's the whole point
of that
anyway whether you get divorced or not
you're having a child so you have to do
all those things thing i'm talking about
like two people just having a chat
a woman's consequence is raising a child
by herself is like saying a man's
consequence for getting divorced is
having to come home from working and he
has to make food for himself
is very different than making a meal
yeah but it's a choice
to support himself through work and that
was the consequence of him and then he's
had a child out there and he hasn't that
man decided to go before you guys are
all saying that men shouldn't be paying
for their kids is that what you're
saying
okay so i told you i'll pay for
everything he clearly said what
mentioned
i said i'll pay for everything i said
i'm not paying for you
i'm not doing that i'm saying the man
should be able to pay for his kid but i
don't think the women is entitled to his
money just because she got a kid off of
him and that incentivizes women to have
bad behavior like stealing a condom and
trying to get a kid off and out but
you're going into that if the money is
coming into the woman's account that she
is going to be using it badly they often
do this is a common complaint this is a
common complaint i hear from men
but how would they know
maybe
that's the solution okay the
accountability is that you should know
where your money is going but without
trying so wouldn't the man know where
the money is going if he spent it on the
kid yeah yeah
right right so
shouldn't the man be able to decide
where his money goes and shouldn't be
able to he's going to do like the
shopping
he's going to buy the clothes he's going
to pay for the school fees whatever it
is that the money that would be going
into the women's account if he does that
there's online shopping you know just
send me the food shop send me
reimbursements
that way right but i'm saying why is she
entitled to child support why can't the
man just spend the money on his own
the the child support should be for the
child yeah and that should be how it is
however between the two of you you go
through your accountability that you are
going to pay for this or it's going to
go into my account and i'm paying for it
this way
there should be child support for the
child to be supported well shouldn't it
be either shouldn't it just be 50 50 50
50 custody and then 50 50. they pay when
it's something in the best case scenario
i think that is exactly how it should be
exactly how it should be but even with
because if you broke up and he was the
higher earner the 50 50 you might want
to have an
elevator why are you entitled to a
better lifestyle no no i'm saying for
the child
i'm saying for the child said you're
saying the 50 50 when the child with the
mum it should be paid for well i know
what you're saying but then i'll just be
like you know what bro mommy's broke fam
that's life
wait when you're here it's it's live in
it when you go home it's beans on toast
yeah that's it this is where it is
the benefit would have been her not
leaving in the first place but now
you've left but you're worried about
what you're doing you're punishing
you're punishing the woman no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no i'm not punishing i'm not punishing
the child because the child can come
stay with me whenever they want i'm not
punishing the child because your mom
left me bro like it's not your fault but
you know you always got a house here boy
so if you want to stay here five days
daddy got five days it's not like if
you're poor like you're what's wrong
with that yeah there's no there's
nothing wrong with that evil yeah
i'm just
you may be punishing
through punishing your wife for like
saying look i'm the better parent you
may punish the child exactly and the way
he's the wife
but no but he'll see his mother as less
than his father and that's what's on the
scene because
no no no no
you can't because
okay but then she should get a job like
the men have to go get it you can work
that's true because
the woman is inherently punishing the
child by divorcing him anyway yes yeah
so yeah if if they're too wrong
that she's now in a situation where she
can't afford the same lifestyle that
husband can that's on her yeah she's not
entitled to the lifestyle you're gonna
exasperate
nuclear family breaks down so we can't
be
like egotistical ignorant of the facts
of knowing the effect it's going to
happen the child so we still need to
maintain the stability of the kids
upbringing while doing what else needs
to be done i'm saying there should be no
incentive
to leave absolutely correct
but i'm saying with child support there
is an incentive
because that money can elevate the life
her lifestyle why why is she entitled to
his money correct me if i'm wrong but
the model we were talking about now was
if the man were to pay for even just for
the child the money let's assume that
the money is going to the child while
while the child is living with the mom
you were saying that he shouldn't pay
but i'm saying if he is going to the
child while he's the child with the
parent this shouldn't be because you're
taking away the consequence of the
expensive cost of a child for the woman
you're again making it easier for her to
leave
she's left now so i'm trying to benefit
my child it should be a teacher she's
already made that bad decision so then
if the man wants to do that he should be
freely able to if he wants he shouldn't
be legally forced yeah her bad decision
he should i think most men want to take
care of their kids and if it ends
amicably most guys are gonna they're
gonna do what's best for the child what
i'm saying is there shouldn't be a gun
to his head saying you have to pay your
baby mama who destroyed your home
especially if he has access most of the
time when i hear guys ain't trying to
pay no money because they can't see
their kids
that's why do you know what i'm saying i
don't hear man that have their kids all
the time saying i ain't giving no money
like i don't hear that so if the guy's
got the access and he's got the 50 um
custody i'm sure he won't mind handing
over the bread and also if a man's
making a lot more than a woman yeah
why is that not taken into account here
when they're doing custody in the first
place because you're talking about the
standard of living for the child if i
make four times more than um the wife
here like you can't tell me that the
kid's not gonna have a better life at my
house exactly that's what but then i
have to pay for
nah nah
and then she's wearing gucci blood when
she's making hm money don't make sense
they think that inherently a woman will
be able to take over the child better
but if i'm making more money that puts
me in a position
you're gonna have to tilt the mic into
yeah sorry man that puts me in a
position where i can then take care of
that child better so if in that
situation if i'm in that situation i
should be given custody but if you're
really old
it depends on time though and there are
lots of cases like usher
he had more money than and tamika and he
had the children the most of the time
there are instances where when the man
is earning more and they do want the
child because they are like i am the
better parent no there's exceptions to
the rules
precisely yes but there are also lots of
fathers who are working a lot and i like
i don't have the time to rear this child
i may have the financial capacity and i
agree that most hedge fund managers say
in your career your successful hedge
fund manager would they want to look
after a child full time if they were if
they were separated from their wife
they're getting that need to be honest
that's what i'm saying the child so
that's gonna be the you you'd be like
let's actually fund
the child's lifestyle so
you know what's crazy i have men in my
dms like guys with check marks with
money status and influence that say they
have problems with child custody that so
they send me their stories and these are
these are men with money so what does
that mean for the average i literally
just said to you i have family members
who are currently in this situation with
their baby mothers now two two kids
apiece literally because they have moved
on are not able to see their kids but
they're not the ones i'm talking about
i'm literally talking about the ones who
if the person has gone and and filed for
child support okay in this country
anyway the money that you're going to
get is really [ __ ] it's not actually
worth it it's not like in america it's
very different you're not going to be
able to fund a lavish lifestyle on what
you're going to be awarded because it's
so calculated it's not that great
mediation
somebody else comes in and you split it
and it's it's
it's custody it's 50 50 custody i think
that is the best number
you left though
but you left though you know i mean if
you used to work at nando's and you left
you ain't getting free chicken normally
yeah like i'm saying i'm talking about
alimony we're talking about child
support the money should be going to
feed and close
though
if he chooses to you should get he
should get the choice if you if you get
left
okay
like like he should get the choice he
shouldn't have a gun to his head saying
oh she left you now you have to pay for
the kid but you should want to this your
is your choice yeah yeah you're right he
should he probably does want to but i'm
saying the government should not make
him because if the woman if the woman's
acting if the woman's acting up and like
like not letting him see the kid or
something he should be able to take away
the money that's yeah he should be able
to but it's not right now
i think that is fair but it's no doubt
it's just like for your child it should
be just like you remove it's just like
if a woman gets pregnant and you say
they're called i don't want to be a dad
and she goes i will too bad and she
keeps to you anyway but they're still
gonna run you down for bread you know i
mean and then on the flip side if you
say yo like i want a child and she says
i don't but if child's gone then you
have to live with the consequences
either way we ain't got no say or
nothing so it's one of them ones where
if you leave
i don't see why i should have to give
you any money i would want to but i
shouldn't have to because you would have
got money if you didn't leave so in this
same scenario where we don't have a say
on anything and i'm saying well you
should just wear a condom i do well you
should have picked better i do
wouldn't that be the same for the woman
when she'd get cheated on when you're
like if you're getting cheated on you
should take responsibility for that
because you pick back is he looking for
the consequences of being cheated on his
difference i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying there should not he should not
have to pay
that's what i'm saying but should he not
have picked better he should have okay
yeah like he should have picked better
but my whole point is that when a man
picks wrong there's a consequence when a
woman picks wrong she takes half
but you're not getting half if you've
just had a child for somebody it's not
hard okay okay even if it's a quarter in
a quarter too much
and a divorce it really does depend on i
i know i know but
that's not the number isn't the point
you understand the point i'm making like
the point is that when a woman makes a
bad decision there's no consequence when
the man makes a bad decision there is
well
that's where we differ because there is
a consequence it even depends on the
society though
because um what you're saying is the
woman would take half right if you go to
arab countries that's not the issue
that's not the case i know but we're not
in it but this is what girls don't
understand clearly but i'm saying
clearly in the context of this
conversation we're talking about the
west yeah of course yeah i'm just
telling you like there are a few cases
that it does not get implemented that
way yes but it's the exception it's not
the rule yeah of course and you can see
marriages last longer then yeah
100 percent
i mean and also in those
cultures and that like man can have
multiple wires and i could do all these
things and a woman's not necessarily
going to leave here just because of that
because she understands of the family
she can but most of the time they don't
because they understand them because
they don't have any other they want to
go backwards
i'll take one for the team
[Laughter]
okay